typical like triggers there's a good
market like it's candidate short
like high growth maybe it's like not
actually that saturated in terms of what
other recruiters doing here yeah and i
guess speaking to
candidates there's lots going on
and there's lots of companies that were
like growing really quickly and the
companies that growing at that time were
like quite small okay so it wasn't like
trying to break into like huge psl yeah
it might be a company that's like five
ten fifteen twenty people that got
really ambitious growth plans so i kind
of mapped out like who are all the
players within this space
who are all the decision makers within
the space and then when you say map out
like just so we get granted here because
everyone says map out your market yeah
yeah like when you say because i'm sure
you help the guys and girls of it now so
like yeah that process is it as simple
as going on linkedin looking at the
people finding out who like is that
literally what you did and then you just
really tried to gather all that
knowledge yeah and then sort of work
away is that how you did that like kind
of but a lot of the really really really
exciting businesses are like the not
obvious ones okay interesting so like if
you look to them on linkedin there might
be like literally a handful of people so
you might not think they're that excited
so i think it's just the kind of general
really good contract recruitment like
when you speak to a candidate you're
doing like cv stripping yeah you're
asking them like obviously what else
they've got going on who are they
speaking to and just being like really
granular trying to use your candidates
to get as much like kind of market
information as possible and then maybe
when you're speaking to your clients
asking them like who's your competitors
within the space and within the
consultancy world consultancies will
partner with other consultancies on bids
right so it might be that we're doing
loads of recruitment for one consultancy
in the database but they might outsource
all their tech development stuff to
another consultancy right so building
relationships with the kind of like
direct disease consultancies they can
say actually this company is doing
similar stuff to actually go and speak
to them yeah and basically just like
systematically did that again and again
and again again and there's probably got
like a list of like 50 yeah and then
we've just kind of worked through that
list of 15. yeah the recruitment mentors
podcast is proudly sponsored by vincerie
who are weaponizing recruiters through
tech and the award-winning sauce breaker
who are transforming the way recruiters
work